c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soit il est bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir cette plainte déposée en
France contre le colonel Mamady
Doumbouya le président de la transition
en Guinée est accusée par des familles
de victimes et le fndc le Front national
pour la défense de la constitution de
complicité domicile et de torture nous
écouterons dans ce journal les avocats
chargés de l'affaire les négociations
entre le Mali et la Côte d'Ivoire qui
piétine le président malien
inconditionne désormais la libération
des 46 militaires ivoiriens détenus à
Bamako par l'extradition de
personnalités politiques maliennes en
exiles en Côte d'Ivoire on fait le point
sur ce tournant dans cette dans un
instant
et puis cette lueur d'espoir en Éthiopie
les autorités tigrées proposent un
cessez-le-feu et se disent ouverte à une
reprise des négociations de paix avec le
gouvernement fédéral sous l'égide de
l'ONU l'Union africaine une main tendue
le jour du Nouvel An éthiopien une fête
gâchée par la guerre et la crise
économique
on commence donc par cette plainte
déposée à Paris contre le président
guinéen de la transition Mamadou
Doumbouya un cabinet d'avocats a été
mandaté par quatre familles de victimes
et la coalition fndc le Front national
pour la défense de la Constitution le
président Doumbouya est accusé de
complicité d'homicides et de torture
lors de la répression des manifestations
contre la gente en juillet et en août
dernier Aline bottin notre chef
d'édition a pu joindre les avocats
chargés de la faire ils reviennent sur
les raisons de cette plainte et sur les
victimes qui se sont constituées partie
civils
il y a eu des actes de torture qui ont
été répertoriés depuis
il y a eu des exécutions
extrajudiciaires l'occasion de mouvement
de protestation
le tout dans un contexte désenchantement
absolu il y a il y avait au départ
une espérance qui se transforme en
illusion c'est à dire que l'origine
d'Alpha condéonie quand un régime est
tonique des gens le remplacent on se dit
ça peut-être mieux et en fait on
retrouve exactement la même mécanique
façon évidemment avec des modalités
différentes mais mais de répression il y
a à la fois donc des éléments qui
permettent de démontrer que Monsieur
doumbouillet aurait une des Françaises
et que par conséquent les auditions
françaises seraient compétentes et dans
le même temps ce mécanisme de la
compétence universelle qui qui permet
donc d'ouvrir la possibilité que des
investigations soient menées en France
c'est une plainte qui a été déposée pour
des familles de victimes pour lesquelles
nous disposons d'un mandat et pour
lesquels de manière au-delà même des
arguments juridiques qui pourraient être
invoqués contre le fndc en revanche leur
intérêt agir ne fait strictement pas le
moindre doute donc il y a vraiment
l'aspect à la fois fndc et intérêt
direct et personnel pour les familles de
victimes notamment de personnes qui ont
été blessées et tués lors des
manifestations qui sont en droit
légalement de pouvoir attendre que la
vérité puisse être puissent s'éclater et
puissent être en tout cassé par les
investigations qui seront faites par le
procureur de réplique en tout cas c'est
ce que nous demande
c'est un marché inacceptable déclaration
d'une source proche de la présidente
ivoirienne à nos confrères de l'AFP ils
réagissait à la nouvelle requête du
président malien le colonel assimigoïta
conditionne désormais la libération des
46 soldats ivoiriens détenus à Bamako à
l'extradition par la Côte d'Ivoire de
personnalités politiques maliennes les
négociations semblent piétiner on fait
le point avec ce reportage de sa diamant
de
jusque là les négociations semblaient
avancées début septembre 3 des 49
militaires Ivoriens accusés par Bamako
d'être des mercenaires ont été vachement
perturbés par le Togo pour libérer les
46 autres soldats continuent et les
autorités ivoiriennes se disaient
confiantes
ces initiatives diplomatiques
nous ont permis
d'avoir ici aujourd'hui avec nous
nos braves soldats
bien évidemment
nous sommes en attente
des 46 autres mais pour la première fois
depuis le début de cette crise Bamako
exige dans une déclaration officielle
que la Côte d'Ivoire leur livre les
personnalités politiques réfugiés dans
le pays parmi eux Karim Keita fils de
l'ancien Président
Ibrahim Boubacar Keita l'ancien Premier
ministre boubou Cissé et lançant
ministre timant Hubert Coulibaly tous
soumanda d'arrêt international mais pour
cette analyse de politique la Côte
d'Ivoire n'acceptera pas facilement
cette demande ça reste assez difficile à
croire parce que la Côte d'Ivoire
elle-même se définit comme étant le pays
de l'hospitalité et il n'a pas de
tradition on va dire de de livrer ce
genre de politique là des états sans
garantie manifeste d'un procès équitable
les autorités ivoiriennes dénoncent une
prise d'otage qui ne restera pas sans
conséquence l'affaire sera portée au
sommet de la CEDEAO cette semaine à New
York
la Côte d'Ivoire compte 3 millions de
ressortissants maliens au nom de
l'amitié entre les deux pays voisins
nombreux appel à la libération des
soldats dernière initiative en date
cette chanson du fameux groupe de
zouglou Ivoiriens Yodé et Siro intitulé
les 49
[Musique]
dans l'as de l'actualité en bref et en
images là convocation de l'opposant
succès massera suspendu jusqu'à nouvel
ordre Tchad annonce du procureur de la
République dans le même temps deux
syndicats de magistrats ont lancé un
appel à la grève pour ce lundi un appel
motivé par des revendications
professionnelles le quatrième
anniversaire de l'accord de paix au
Soudan du Sud cet accord entre le
président salvaquir et le vice-président
n'a pas apporté la paix et la stabilité
attendue la période de transition qui
doit aboutir à des élections a été
prolongée de deux ans début août
l'ambassadeur israélien à Rabat rappelé
dans son pays selon la presse
israélienne David Govrin serait accusé
entre autres d'abus sexuels il y a
quelques jours une délégation du
ministère israélien des Affaires
étrangères s'était rendu au Maroc pour y
entendre des employés de l'ambassade
le président de la transition au Burkina
Faso en tournée régionale le colonel
d'hannibas s'est rendu ce dimanche à
Niamey au Niger une visite qui a pour
objectif de créer un front unique contre
le terrorisme le pays se remet
difficilement de la dernière attaque le
5 septembre dernier au moins 37
personnes ont été tuées par les
djihadistes le point avec notre envoyé
spécial à Ouagadougou ange no Manio
après le Mali et la Côte d'Ivoire le
président du Burkina Faso Paul-Henri
Damiba s'est rendu au Niger ce dimanche
11 septembre l'objectif de ces visites
bien clair faire en front comme un
contre le terrorisme qui continue de
sévir dans la région après l'attaque du
5 septembre qui a coûté la vie à 35
personnes dont des enfants d'autres
attaques ont été enregistrées dans le
nord du pays une coalition sous
régionale s'avère donc plus que
nécessaire pour le président du Faso et
c'est le point de vue de l'analyse
politique Dieudonné zungrana je pense
que le déplacement du président Damiba
au Mali s'imposait parce que tous deux
sont vraiment ce qu'on dirait un peu les
maillons faibles dans dans ce cette
texte G5 là dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme alors s'ils peuvent faire un
front avec le Niger notamment je pense
que c'est tout bénef vraiment je pense
que aujourd'hui la mutualisation des
forces entre le Burkina le Mali et le
Niger peuvent en tout cas du reprendra
dans la lutte contre les croquants
sanguinaires qui écument en tout cas la
sous-région depuis plusieurs années le
Burkina Faso fait face aujourd'hui à une
crise grandissante les autorités
transitaires en tant que fait de la
lutte contre le terrorisme leur
priorités ils ont jusqu'à 2024 pour
avoir des résultats c'est le temps que
va durer leur transition mais pour
beaucoup d'analystes ce temps nous
suffira pas pour enrayer de manière
définitive le phénomène de terrorisme
en République démocratique du Congo le
président de l'Union pour la nation
congolaise vital camere a entamé ce
lundi une tournée politique dans l'est
du pays a quitté par la justice l'ancien
chef de cabinet du président Tshisekedi
a fait une première escale à Goma
chef-lieu de la province du Nord qui
vous il a pu y tenir un meeting
populaire je vous propose de l'écouter
je suis venu ici pour remonter le moral
de mes compatriotes
et leur dire que cette guerre nous
allons la finir
cette guerre nous allons la finir
[Applaudissements]
même s'il reste une seule personne dans
le Nord qui vous lis Touri le sud qui
vous Katanga
personne ne va rester là éternellement
Éthiopie le gouvernement régional du
Tigré a proposé l'ouverture d'un
processus de paix sous l'égide de
l'Union africaine une médiation que les
rebelles du Tigré refusaient jusque là
une annonce faite à l'occasion de la
nouvelle année du calendrier éthiopien
une fête entachée par la guerre et la
crise économique cabinet d'ellec
c'est un moment de joie et normalement
d'abondance mais cette année le nouvel
an en Éthiopie est plus sobre que
d'habitude le chant reste gratuit
mais le prix du bétail a explosé et les
gens ont réduit leurs achats en juillet
dernier l'inflation a dépasser les 33%
j'avais l'habitude d'acheter des moutons
pour environ 5000 Birds mais aujourd'hui
c'est 15000 Birs certaines personnes
m'ont moins de revenus elles ne peuvent
plus se permettre cela la situation
actuelle est donc très difficile
la Banque mondiale déplore plusieurs
chocs économiques qui mettent en péril
le développement du pays l'Éthiopie fait
face à une sécheresse historique
l'instabilité outils Grey perdure et la
guerre nucléaire est une nette l'arrivée
des graines depuis février même avec la
crise de covid en 2020 les marchés
étaient restés bondés mais cette année
la crise économique de Cell est le
nombre de clients
l'inflation a eu son impact si les gens
avaient suffisamment d'argent il aurait
plus de monde
les Nations Unies ont envoyé assez de
provisions pour nourrir un million cinq
cent mille personnes pour un mois une
aide qui va prendre plusieurs semaines
avant d'arriver au plus démunis alors
qu'une vingtaine de millions de
personnes souffrent de faim
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'Afrique restez avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de Paris direct avec
Nadia markloufi
[Musique]